look at me i know it's challenge break
but good lord my right elbow is broken
my
left hand is fractured here at my wrist
even though your arm's in a cast i'm so
happy that you are okay after taking a
pretty scary fall during last week's
live shows
we okay on stage
wendy moton was back on the voice monday
night ready to compete with a broken
elbow it's literally shocking just a
little refresher last week wendy had
just crushed a performance of i can't
help myself with her coach blake shelton
and her teammates lana scott and paris
winningham when she unexpectedly hit the
ground while walking off stage
and a big okay on stage
everybody all right
take a quick second we just had somebody
fall
cameras quickly cut away from wendy and
host carson daly attempted to let fans
know what was going on
unfortunate
event from wendy mouton
who is walking off and we hope she's
okay
and when the show came back from
commercial break wendy assured viewers
she was a-okay
yes i'm okay i'm a little bruised but
you know what i'm still ready to go well
after the show she went to the hospital
only to learn she had broken her right
elbow and fractured her left wrist
we were going to do rehearsals that
night and you were in the hospital i
fell down pretty hard monday night wendy
took the stage like a champ and after
wowing the coaches with her cover of
dolly parton's hit jolene
[Music]
she got some high praise from her coach
who was impressed with the way she
pushed through a tough week
america i've never seen a better example
of strength and perseverance
and fearlessness standing on this stage
not losing focus of what she came here
to do which is to win this thing
we've got to go to the finale mindy come
on
of course it's no secret blake is a big
fan of wendy's after landing the
four-chair turn to his team during the
blind auditions he has repeatedly said
that she's the most deserving singer
he's ever coached in fact here's what he
said after her top 20 performance
earlier this season hey wendy i'm going
to say this i'm probably gonna catch a
lot of heat for it but i don't care
i don't care
i've been doing this show for 21 seasons
now as a coach
and there is nobody that i want this
more
for
ever for you
you you deserve this and following her
performance on monday the country singer
tweeted his love writing quote america
did you see what wendy moton just did
what a comeback performance so proud of
her
pretty major right and his reaction to
wendy is a big deal because when e.t
caught up with blake and his fellow
coach ariana grande recently he admitted
he sometimes doesn't exactly show a ton
of emotion i don't have a big reaction
do i
no
no
you're jaded now yeah if you said who
has the least reaction to anything
it's john legend
but kelly like jumps up like out of her
chair and like she can't
ever play anything cool like it's
wonderful though it makes people feel so
good about it you know and then they pan
to you and
and what
whatever you know come on this is where
this is where you jab this is where you
jab
come on let me have it let me have it
ari i'm kidding i don't have anything
[Music]
you